[Musique]
bon
le livre de victor castanet a révélé
avec une ampleur insoupçonnée
des dysfonctionnements pour ne parler
que de ça sur les ehpad qui révélait un
manque de contrôle donc c'est un le
point de départ de notre mission c'est
comment est-ce que l'on contrôle
aujourd'hui les établissements qui
accueillent les personnes âgées en
sachant qu'elle a à peu près la moitié
qui sont des établissements publics
un quart des établissements privés à but
non lucratif c'est dire associative aux
autres et un quart à but lucratif on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que ces 25% de
privés à but lucratif pose un peu un
problème d'opacité c'est avant tout les
agences régionales de santé et les
départements qui sont les financeurs qui
contrôle la question est est-ce
suffisant ou est ce la manière dont il
faut le faire puisqu'on voit que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas au père en est
que les profits immenses que se font les
grands groupes passent au travers des
contrôles et puis après il ya la
question de qui fait le contrôle moi je
pense que ceux qui paient doivent aussi
vérifier
le bon usage des deniers publics parce
qu'il s'agit de bienne ça c'est de
l'argent public qui est dépensé
il y aura un nouveau gouvernement au
mois de juin on le rendra slam à la fin
juin probablement et pour mettre la
pression sur le nouveau gouvernement qui
sera mis en place il faut absolument
qu'ils aient un engagement fort du du
prochain du candidat qui sera élu ou la
candidate pour que avant la fin d'année
on est ce toi grand âge et les moyens
qui vont avec